Hey listeners, Ted Danson here. If you enjoyed my recent episode on smartness, as much as I did, you may enjoy my new podcast where everybody knows your name with me and my good friend and co-host Woody Harrelson. Woody and I were great friends and worked together obviously on Cheers for eight, nine years together and then went our different ways. We'd see each other every once in a while. We thought that this podcast would be a great way to get to know each other again and to share the friends we've met on our different paths. So we're having a great time.
听众们好，我是特德·丹森。如果你和我一样喜欢我最近关于“聪明”的那期节目，你可能也会喜欢我的新播客《每个人都知道你的名字》，我和我的好朋友兼联合主持人伍迪·哈里森一起主持。伍迪和我曾经是非常要好的朋友，我们在《干杯酒吧》合作了八、九年，然后各奔东西。我们偶尔会见面。我们觉得这个播客是一个重新了解彼此、分享我们在不同人生道路上结识的朋友的好方法。所以我们过得很开心。
You'll hear some great guests on the show, like Kristen Bell, Conan O'Brien, Jeff Goldblum, Lisa Kudrow, and Will Arnett. That's right, we were lucky enough to get Will for our very first episode. Check out the clip now. Ted, I think about this, about what you've done all the time. Both you guys have gone from there, from Cheers, you've had no fewer than five hit television shows since then that I can think of. You had Becker, Good Place.
你会在节目中听到一些很棒的嘉宾，比如克里斯汀·贝尔、柯南·奥布莱恩、杰夫·高布伦、莉莎·库卓和威尔·阿奈特。没错，我们很幸运能请到威尔来录制我们的第一期节目。现在来看看这段剪辑。特德，我一直在想这件事，关于你所做过的一切。你们俩从《干杯酒吧》之后，据我能想到的，你们至少拍了五部大热的电视剧。你有《贝克尔》、《善地》。
Damages. Damages. I forgot about Damages. The one with the Board to Death. Board to Death. Board to Death. I love that one. With Zach and, yeah. This is great podcast, by the way. No, but it's true.
《法网裂痕》。《法网裂痕》。我都忘了《法网裂痕》了。那部叫《无聊至死》。《无聊至死》。《无聊至死》。我很喜欢那部。有扎克还有……是的。顺便说一句，这是一个很棒的播客。不，但这是真的。
And you made all those movies. You made all those Curb episodes. Curb episodes. Made tons of movies in between. Woody, you made a million movies and limited series and comedies and dramas. And I get the sense that both of you guys don't feel like you've got it figured out.
而且你拍了所有那些电影。你拍了所有那些《抑制热情》的剧集。《抑制热情》剧集。中间拍了大量的电影。伍迪，你拍了无数的电影、限定剧、喜剧和剧情片。我感觉你们两个好像都觉得自己还没完全搞懂这一切。
So maybe you had a moment where you thought you were a big shot, but I don't buy it. But it's a little bit of the actor's illness. You never think you're good enough. You always feel a little bit like an imposter. You always don't think you're going to get another job. Yeah. I mean, I don't think that goes away.
所以也许你有那么一刻觉得自己是个大人物，但我才不买账。不过这有点像是演员的毛病。你永远觉得不够好。你总是觉得自己有点像个冒名顶替者。你总是觉得你不会再找到下一份工作。是的。我是说，我觉得这种感觉不会消失。
Let's heap some praise onto you. Oh, yeah. Before you heap the praise, can I ask you guys a question? Yeah. Do you ever have that thing when you're Oh yeah, before you heap the praise, can I ask you guys a question? Yeah, do you want to go to the bathroom? Do you ever have that thing when you're like in a room with a bunch of Hollywood types and you feel kind of like the... It's my life.
让我们对你大加赞赏吧。哦，是的。在你赞赏之前，我能问你们一个问题吗？是的。你有没有那种时候……哦，是的，在你赞赏之前，我能问你们一个问题吗？是的，你想去洗手间吗？你有没有那种时候，比如你和一群好莱坞名流在一个房间里，然后你觉得自己有点像……这就是我的生活。
You don't feel like you belong, like you were just saying, like... Totally. I used to imagine that I had a... You walk into these parties and I felt like there was a number on a piece of paper that stuck to my back, my ranking in Hollywood. Come on, really? Yes! And you'd sit there and you'd reach around and go, fuck! 1,200? Really? I'm the 1,200th? No, you know.
你觉得自己不属于这里，就像你刚才说的，就像……完全是这样。我以前常常想象自己有……你走进这些派对，我感觉贴在我后背上有一张写着数字的纸条，那就是我在好莱坞的排名。拜托，真的吗？是的！然后你会坐在那里，把手伸到背后去抓，操！1,200名？真的吗？我是第1,200名？不，你知道的。
You never had that, did you? Not really. You're like, I belong in this room, and everybody loves me. Not only do I belong, but these fucking people are the worst. They're so untalented. I can't believe how lucky all these motherfuckers are. This person can barely read. This person can barely speak.
你从来没有过那种感觉，对吧？没有吧。你会想，我属于这个房间，每个人都爱我。我不属于这里，而且这群混蛋简直是烂透了。他们太没有才华了。我简直不敢相信所有这些王八蛋有多幸运。这个人几乎不识字。这个人几乎不会说话。
That's so healthy. I love that. You're like, I own this room. I fucking kill it. No, you do have those things. I mean, I've gone through very, again, I think that it's one of the benefits of getting older that I just put less value on shit like that.
这太健康了。我喜欢这样。你会想，这个房间是我的。我简直太棒了。不，你确实有这种感觉。我是说，我经历过很多次，再说一次，我觉得变老的好处之一就是我对这种破事看得更轻了。
And there was a time coming off of rest of development, if I'm being totally honest, where I thought that I was gonna have, where I had a lot of opportunity and I felt like I squandered it, which reminds me, I gotta fire my manager today. And I've had those moments where I was like, I could have had this or I could have had that,
有一段时间，在《发展受阻》之后，如果我实话实说的话，我觉得自己会有，我有很多机会，而我觉得自己把它给挥霍了，这让我想起，我今天得炒了我经纪人的鱿鱼。我有过那些时刻，我想着我本可以拥有这个，或者我本可以拥有那个，
and I didn't. And I always remind myself that I'm on my path. The universe is always taking care of me. So whatever that's gonna be, and I don't know what is coming for me but it's fucking great and it is right around the corner and you know how I know that because it always has been. So I just got a bank on that. It's the only thing that's kind of the only faith I really have. If you want to hear the
而我没有。我总是提醒自己，我正走在自己的道路上。宇宙一直在照顾我。所以无论那将是什么，我不知道有什么在等着我，但它他妈的太棒了，而且就在拐角处，你知道我为什么知道吗？因为一直都是这样。所以我只能押注于此。这是我仅有的真正信念。如果你想听
rest of our conversation head over to where everybody knows your name to listen to the rest of Will's episode now or you can head over to Where Everybody Knows Your Name to listen to the rest of Will's episode now. Or you can head over to YouTube and watch it. And be sure to subscribe and follow wherever you get your podcasts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们谈话的其余部分，请前往《每个人都知道你的名字》收听威尔那一期的剩余部分，或者你可以前往《每个人都知道你的名字》收听威尔那一期的剩余部分。或者你可以去YouTube观看。请务必订阅并关注你获取播客的任何地方。这期节目目前还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。